unos resultados muy tranquilizadores así
calificaron el cerca 91 por ciento de
efectividad de la vacuna the fighter en
la prevención de infecciones
sintomáticas en los niños de 5 a 11 años
belfort genes ya para hemos tenido la
suerte de tener una vacuna eficaz y muy
segura para los adultos y adolescentes
durante los últimos meses y ahora estos
datos muestran que también tenemos una
vacuna muy eficaz para los niños de 5 a
11 años a venir se ve en la vacuna se
diferencia a la de los adultos al tener
una menor cantidad del biológico y se
espera que se comience a aplicar desde
el próximo mes si comparamos las
respuestas de anticuerpos en
adolescentes y adultos jóvenes con la de
niños de 5 a 11 años de edad que reciben
una dosis más baja podemos ver que sus
niveles de anticuerpos son igual de
fuertes y eso nos permite usar una dosis
que es aproximadamente un 70% más baja a
pesar de que el estudio no descarta
efectos secundarios de los dos mil 268
niños que participaron en la
investigación ninguno presentó
enfermedades graves
se espera que la administración de
medicamentos y alimentos debata la
evidencia la próxima semana el gobierno
estadounidense anunció hace unos días
que de aceptar su uso comenzará a enviar
millones de dosis a todo el país
estaremos listos a la espera de la
decisión de la fed y los cdc ésta se
basará en la ciencia pero queremos
asegurarnos de que las operaciones estén
listas para que se acomoden a los niños
que la vacuna ya está autorizada para el
uso en mayores de 12 años pero la
administración de joe biden espera
ampliar el rango aún a pesar de los
reparos de ciertos sectores de la
sociedad